[Música]
não gente nós não são gêmeas
a nossa diferença de idade é de exatos
11 meses a nossa diferença de idade é
sempre constrangedor porque pra você que
fez as contas você percebeu que eu
estava grávida quando ela ainda tinha
dois meses
isso aí no meu aniversário de um ano já
estava então a partir daí eu descobri
que toda a minha vida seria
compartilhada
os meus pais guarda roupa dos meus
sonhos já dividimos um brunch isso em
outro lugar que a gente fala mas enfim
tudo foi compartilhado mas o que mais
motiva hoje é o sonho que nós
compartilhamos e por causa desse sonho
que é compartilhado que nós estamos
compartilhando esse palco também
tudo começou em 2010 último ano de
faculdade do curso de biomedicina e nós
estamos felizes por um lado porque
aquela empolgação ao voltar livre disso
graças a deus mas por outro lado que vou
fazer agora preciso de um emprego
preciso estabilidade
a nossa dificuldade é que esse nunca foi
nosso sonho de verdade nós somos filhos
de um moçambicano casado com uma
brasileira e neto de uma americana a
nossa casa parece reunião da onu quando
a família se junta a gente sempre sonhou
em conhecer o mundo mas não conhecer
pontos turísticos mas conhecer pessoas e
mudar a vida de pessoas
isso é meio difícil quando a gente
imagina que nós vamos passar pelo menos
mais 30 anos trabalhando oito horas
dentro de um laboratório tendo esperando
o salário no final do mês para que
finalmente a gente tem uma casa legal um
carro legal e três refeições por dia e
toda vez que compartilhava esse sonho
com alguém ou mesmo colocar aquela
desculpa dentro de mim que nós eu quero
fazer algo mas eu não tenho grana mesmo
é de resolução contados para fazer check
in da faculdade quanto mais fazer algo
relevante e aí um dia enquanto nós
estávamos conversando sobre essa
publicidade que a gente vivia
nós pensamos que os nossos pais iriam
gastar nos próximos meses cerca de oito
mil reais nas quatro solenidade de
formatura e aí veio a idéia brenda por
que então o que a gente não deixa de
lado essas festas de formatura pede
dinheiro dos nossos pais e vamos enfim
fazer aquilo que ele realmente quer
perfeito resolver os nossos problemas
só que convencer os nossos pais não era
tarefa fácil
então nós saímos uma série de argumentos
ramos chamamos ele pra conversar ea
conversa foi bem assim
a e seguinte nós queremos trocar nossa
festa de formatura
a fazer uma viagem nessa viagem nós
queremos ficar três meses
nós queremos e para qualquer país do
continente africano e lá nós vamos
trabalhar como como voluntários
aquele silêncio na sala meu pai depois
de algum tempo disse sim ea minha
resposta foi calma homem deixa eu falar
meus argumentos
o mais legal de tudo isso é que dois
meses depois nós estávamos embarcando
pra melhor formatura de todas que a
formatura da vida e na formatura da vida
acontece algo interessante porque as
provas acontecem antes das eleições e
nós a primeira lição que nós aprendemos
depois disso é que na verdade só não
custam nada como as pessoas falam vamos
falar a sonhar não custa nada a gente
custa tudo
quando você tem um sonho de verdade é
que está a sua madrugada e vai custar
suas decisões e vai custar as pessoas
com quem você anda com quem você deixa
de andar um sonho de verdade vai custar
às vezes até seu nome um sonho de
verdade vai custar as festas você deixa
de ir à formatura que você deixa de
fazer
mas quem sabe a gente vale a pena vale
muito a pena porque aqueles três meses
nós estávamos lá nos revezávamos em três
hospitais para fazer o atendimento e nos
finais de semana nós duas também são as
bailarinas
a gente usava é essa a nossa habilidade
para poder dar aula de dança para
crianças e adolescentes então foi uma
imersão muito legal
era uma aula de dança qualquer começava
com o aquecimento e depois de sairmos de
lá de fato os passos e neste final de
semana nos dez primeiros minutos de aula
ou me lá no fundo começou a chorar muito
só que não era aquele choro de bebida de
criança era aquele choro da alma
quando pedi para ela ver o que estava
acontecendo ela sempre pede nem vai lá
querida vai cuidar da criança chorando
enquanto a mudança ela faz isso comigo
mas quando cheguei ali pra falar com
aquela criança eu entendi que os olhos
também falam porque ela não precisou
responder por causa do choro dela ela
olhou para os pés dela e aí aquele olhar
para os pais dela me fez olhar pra mim
também onde estava porque estava dando
aula de dança para crianças em um
deserto às duas horas da tarde no chão
que era só areia areia quente lugar que
não tinha teto as chapas de zinco de um
metro e meio para baixo e aquela criança
estava ali com os pés cheios de ferida e
cada passo que ela fazia quem entrava no
perdeu
eu falei falei pra ela espera não você
não quiser fazer essa obra desse jeito
vai calçar chinelos e ela disse não
tinha mas eu não tenho um chinelo e não
tem problema a gente está só começando
lá em casa calçando chinelo e volta e
ela desiste e eu não tenho parte dela
naquele momento entendi que a nossa vida
não pode ser só nossa
naquele momento entendi que não faz o
menor sentido eu achar que fazendo algo
de interessante no mundo faz a criança
dançarem descalço no deserto enquanto eu
tô calçada se colocar no lugar do outro
é mais do que tirar fotos se colocar no
lugar do outro é mais do que você
imaginar que está lidando aquilo que a
pessoa quer receber se colocar no lugar
do outro e senti a dor no pé daquela
menina e foi aquilo que eu passei a
sentir aquele dia aquilo que nós
passamos a sentir naquele dia
nós esperamos muito por aquela
oportunidade está ali com aquelas
crianças da nossa viagem nós levamos uma
mala cheia
só que como cheia de coisa para nós nós
nós cabe a nós usam tinha espaço para
mais ninguém
nós nós é o tema do nosso encontro hoje
uma palavra com três letras e é
engraçado que todos nós queremos coisas
melhores pra nós mas quantas pessoas
cabem essas três letras quando está
falando que você quer coisa melhor pra
nós de quem exatamente você está falando
porque naquele momento quando lembrava
da minha mala eu sabia que se levasse em
angola eu ia te roupa ocasião mas era
tudo pra gente e aí nós estamos num
lugar em que o salário mínimo custava
cerca de 120 dólares e um par de chinelo
custava 40 dólares
imagina você pai e mãe com dois três
filhos recebendo os 120 dólares e tendo
que escolher quem é que você vai calçar
naquele mês quando nós voltamos pro
brasil
nós entendemos que o nosso nós poderiam
ser aquelas 250 crianças que deixamos
para trás 100 pares de chinelo ea idéia
era muito simples nós chamamos os nossos
amigos da companhia de dança
fizemos fotos com eles editamos as fotos
também são os designers e começamos a
elaborar textos que contavam sobre
aquela situação para que as pessoas
pudessem simplesmente doar um par de
chinelo e no dia 13 de outubro de 2012
nós fizemos a primeira publicação com as
nossas fotos explicando a
história e com a hashtag 2 nelson
empolgação era muito porque eu pensava
agora sim nós vamos conseguir fazer algo
no primeiro dia não teve nenhuma curtida
nenhum comentário nem o compartilhamento
nada e antes de dormir nós pensamos
nossa não dá para pagar tudo isso acho
que vai ser muito difícil 250 pares de
chinelo é muita coisa pra gente
arrecadar não vai dar mas outro dia
antes de nós acordarmos quando nós
contou com a companhia de casa alguém
deixou uma sacola com o meu pai e assim
chegar os seis primeiros pares de
chinelos no final daquela semana o nosso
carro ficou cheio dos 100 primeiros
pares de chinelos e na outra semana nós
já tínhamos os 250 pares de chinelos mas
mais do que isso nós tínhamos pedido de
outras pessoas do haiti e da índia
falando eu também não tem chinelo se
sobrar daí você pode mandar pra cá o ano
de 2013 foi incrível
nós falamos da campanha dois chinelos
nos 43 dos 43 52 finais de semana e em
17 estados brasileiros têm patrocínio
nenhum agente falavam de da oportunidade
nesse mesmo ano nós atingimos 5.000 par
de chinelos e nós aprendemos a segunda
lição é que quando você tem um sonho
você passa a ser identificado por ele
eu conheço o jônatas que quer ser
militar eu também conheço a sara que ela
sonhou com odontologia e hoje ela sai
prestando atendimento em comunidades
carentes 2 ruas a partir de então passou
a ser conhecida como as meninas do
chinelo era se chegava no mercado
fazendo compras com os nossos pais
também falei vocês são aquelas meninas
que arrecadam janela de raiva assim a
pessoa ir lá comprar dinheiro que estava
no nosso carro então o que nós
entendemos é que um sonho de verdade
além de custar o teu tempo vai custar
sua identidade
você vai ser identificado por aquilo que
queima no teu coração você vai passar só
uma pessoa vai ser uma causa
nós estamos aqui não percebeste branda
no meu interesse em estar aqui hoje com
vocês não é que vocês olham pra gente
falou valcke legal que elas fazem
o interesse está aqui é que você se
escute através de nós é que você volte a
dar moral pra aquela voz com dia tocou
no seu coração e falar poxa eu posso
fazer isso
nós não temos fotos nós não queremos
mostrar a pobreza que a gente tem visto
ao redor do mundo
nós não queremos mostrar que existem
pessoas piores que a gente não é esse o
objetivo de uma ação social
às vezes as pessoas nos procuram falando
assim
meu filho numa viagem que você ficar
dando trabalho quando ele vê o que vocês
vêem ele vai melhorar
não nós não somos pessoas que precisam
ver pobreza do outro é se sentir melhor
nós somos pessoas que precisam se olhar
no espelho entender porque nós temos
vivido essa pobreza de propósito apesar
de tanta coisa
o que nós queremos aqui hoje é que você
se imagina que é que você imagine as
fotos que você poderia está apresentando
aqui o que você poderia ter feito e não
está fazendo porque às vezes pode ser
difícil
nós chegamos a 5 mil pares de chinelo
primeiro ano 10 mil pares no segundo ano
23 mil para o 3º ano e essa semana nós
alcançamos a marca de 41 mil pares de
chinelos
além disso você pode pensar o aoki legal
elas quatro vezes a meta inicial mas a
gente não quer parar por aqui
agora nós temos uma nova marca à marca
de 100 mil pares de chinelos
nós queremos nós estamos construindo
escola de artesanato e empreendedorismo
para mulheres em situações de risco
também levamos saúde em comunidades
carentes porque nós entendemos que a
nossa vida não precisa ser só nós um
sonho quando ele é compartilhada um
sonho quando ele é destinado a outro ele
dá o poder de imortalidade para uma
pessoa por que eu vou passar ela vai
passar e vocês vão passar mas aquilo que
vocês deixarem aqui vai ficar talvez
você esteja com menor idéia de que você
pode fazer a sua vida
nós trouxemos uma pequena sugestão pra
vocês
essa foi a nossa última viagem nós
voltamos a dez dias de angola e nesses
oito anos nós conhecemos mais e mais e
mais pessoas que não sabiam caminho todo
que não tinham tudo para oferecer mas
fizeram parte do que tinha e parte do
que tinha foi o suficiente para mudar a
vida de alguém
nessa clube quer rio queda foi de 15 em
franco a nada mas o desafio meia hora de
trabalho no brasil e assim na briga para
não cair rapidamente
os direitos humanos são direitos que são
garantidos a pessoa pelo simples fato de
ser humana são inerentes à sua condição
e natura consistindo em direitos e
liberdades básicos considerados
fundamentais para sua dignidade
[Música]
não tô
é d
ei já ó
até
ah
[Música]
ó
eg dó
eis a hora
ó israel
ó
[Música]
o arraiá chão
o bahia
o mundo
[Música]
o risco de queda forte nos provar nada
o primeiro desafio
isso é pra ninguém
foi assim que acabei caindo
em 1948 a onu organização das nações
unidas adotou uma declaração universal
dos direitos humanos o documento que
conforme o próprio nome indica não visa
constituir direitos mas apenas declarar
em reconhecer os direitos já existentes
ressaltando a dignidade inerente a todos
os membros da família humana os seus
direitos igualitários são inalienáveis
constituindo o fundamento da liberdade
da justiça e da paz no mundo
independentemente do contexto cultural
envolvido mas prevalecendo sempre a
natureza humana e os direitos que lhe
são paulo
[Música]
i am
o poeta
[Música]
o dólar
[Aplausos]
promover os direitos humanos ea justiça
social é um ato de compromisso com o
próximo
quebrando a cadeia de goey smo e fazendo
da sua própria vida um caminho por onde
flui acompanhou
[Música]
eu tô aqui pra dizer que uma viagem de
mudar sua vida porque talvez você não
vai chegar viajar
eu tô aqui pra dizer que você tem que
arrecadar 50 100 mil pares de chinelo
porque não só os números que nos define
eu tô aqui pra dizer que quando você
consegue olhar para outra pessoa
enxergar a palavra nós quando você
entender que na verdade não existe outro
mas que o outro é simplesmente você em
outra situação
então você vai entender que a sua
estadia que por essa terra pode ser algo
muito maior do que você pensa
então você tem uma motivação melhor para
estudar para trabalhar para fazer o que
for a minha crise aqui hoje é porque
acreditar nesse palco estava ali naquela
mesa e eu estava em dúvida se eu vim pra
cá de tênis o seu grande salto
a gente brigou causa disso porque eu
queria vencer o que ela queria muito
tempo e que poesia de vida essa em que a
minha maior crise escolher o sapato erro
enquanto hoje existem 300 milhões de
pessoas que não têm o que calçar não é
só parte nela a nossa causa hoje é um
pedaço de borracha
a nossa causa hoje lembrar que há 15
dias atrás nós encontramos uma menina
que depois de nos ouvir e ofereceu três
reais para comprar um par de chinelo em
angola eu falei pra ela que não estava
ali para vender um par de chinelo mas
ela disse tia hoje é domingo na quinta
feira minha mãe me deixou em casa
cuidando dos meus irmãos menores e
quando ela voltou ela sentiu falta de
500 quando ainda mais ou menos sete
reais e ela diz que foi ela me bateu e
me expulsou de casa
se você me der um par de chinelo que vou
te lembrar lá custa 45 dólares
se você me der um par de chinelo dia ela
vai deixar voltar pra casa tinha me veio
do partido não são parte nem da gente
não é só o tempo do seu da sua vida
talvez um pouquinho que você tem pra
oferecer hoje vai ser transformado em
milhares e milhares de pessoas voltando
para um lugar em que elas vão poder de
chamar de casa olhando essa terra e
poder enfim chamar essa terra de casa um
lugar em que ela só
lindas nosso desejo é que a sua vida
seja de fato uma vida de compaixão
porque compaixão
nós costumamos dizer que a maneira que
deus o que qualquer coisa que você
acredite nos deu para enxergar o mundo
através dos olhos dele
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]